Jessica Biel revealed her son is a mini
Justin Timberlake and our hearts are
bursting he's the coolest kid I felt
like intimidated hangout I feel a little
intimidated by him too
[Music]
the sinner star stopped by the Tonight
Show Starring Jimmy Fallon on Tuesday
and revealed her two-year-old son Silas
Randall already has a killer sense of
fashion and she gave all the credit to
her famous hubby it's kind of like a
mini Justin you know it's it's his style
daddy swagger the 35 year old actress
and the Tonight Show host also
reminisced about their joint family
vacation and what it took to get Justin
and Jimmy's bro biking video just right
we definitely did take two but before
just sat down with her husband's bestie
she made sure to get camera-ready
hosting a pic of herself eating in the
shower mom life is busy and this clip of
her newly painted nails with the caption
what you thought I wasn't gonna get a
mani for my date with my husband's
boyfriend at Jimmy Fallon later in the
show the two teamed up against Matt
Bomer and Kelsea Ballerini for a game of
charades and just hilariously dropped
the ball trying to guess Justin's hit
cry me a river
[Music]
you